Okay. Guten Tag, mein Name ist Enes Uchunju und ich bin der Dienstabend Arzt. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Jochen Schäfer.
Jochen Schäfer. Können Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachname bitte langsam stabilieren?
Ja, der Vorname J U C H E N und der Familienname S C H E, also A umlaut, F E R.
F E R.
F E R. Schäfer.
Schäfer, okay.
Wie der Schafhüter, ja.
Okay. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
48, okay. Wann genau wurden Sie geboren?
Am 17.04.1977.
177. Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,83 Meter.
1,83 Meter, okay. Kennen Sie Ihr aktuelles Gewicht?
Also um die 90 Kilo wiege ich immer.
90, okay. Danke für all diese Informationen. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, das ist jetzt heute Abend, da hat es erst angefangen vor zwei Stunden, habe ich ganz heftige Schmerzen und zwar so hier hinten im Rücken, im unteren Rücken auf der rechten Seite.
Und das sind solche Schmerzen, das krampft sich alles so zusammen und das strahlt auch aus bis in den Genitalbereich rein und das ist mir schon den ganzen Tag eigentlich aufgefallen, dass es beim Wasserlassen so ein bisschen brennt und dass ich ständig auf die Toilette gehen muss.
Aber jetzt mit einmal diese starken Schmerzen, da habe ich gedacht, jetzt muss ich doch was unternehmen.
Also okay, es tut mir sehr leid, dass Sie solche Schmerzen haben. Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Ja, ich würde auch.
Oder müssen Sie jetzt mit jemandem sprechen?
Entschuldigung?
Ich denke schon, dass ich das auslade, so lange wird es ja jetzt nicht dauern.
Okay, danke. Ich werde eine sehr... Wo genau haben Sie diese Beschwerden? Sie haben gesagt hinten rechten...
Ja, also im Rücken so an der Seite.
Eine Seite, okay. Sie haben gesagt seit heute Abend.
Ja, also das ist jetzt, dass das so heftige Schmerzen sind, das ist erst seit zwei Stunden.
Aber ich habe das tatsüber schon gemerkt, dass ich ständig zur Toilette muss, ja.
Okay, okay. Haben Sie für diese Beschwerden ein Schmerzmittel genommen?
Nein, das hat ja jetzt erst so schlimm angefangen. Ich habe relativ viel getrunken, weil ich dachte, wenn das so brennt beim Wasserlassen,
das ist gut, wenn ich ein bisschen Wasser trinke und Tee. Aber Medikamente habe ich jetzt noch nicht genommen.
Okay, okay. Das war eine gute Idee. Viel zu trinken ist eine gute Idee. Super.
Hätten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden schon einmal?
So etwas kenne ich überhaupt gar nicht, nein.
Okay. Wie beschreiben Sie diese Beschwerden? Sind sie drückend, stechend oder?
Also wie gesagt beim Wasserlassen, das sind so richtig brennende, stechende Schmerzen.
Und diese Schmerzen da im Rücken, ja, würde ich sagen, ja, das ist eher drückend, ja.
Ich verstehe. Zur besseren Beurteilung, wo würden Sie diese Beschwerden auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10 einordnen?
Wobei nur 1 nur Leichtschmerzen und 10 unträgliche Schmerzen bedeutet.
Unerträglich, das ist unerträglich. Also bei 7 oder 8 sind sie bestimmt, ja.
7, 7, okay. Sie haben gesagt, das Stahl aus zum Genital, oder?
Ja, in die Leiste und bis ins Genital rein, ja. Ganz unangenehm, ja.
Okay, gibt es vielleicht einen Auslöser? Zum Beispiel was kalt oder es gibt bestimmte Nahrungsmittel?
Nein, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, dass es irgendwas gibt, was das ausgelöst hat.
Okay, okay. Begleitet etwas Ihre Beschwerden? Haben Sie bemerkt?
Also ich musste mich tatsächlich vorhin einmal übergeben, aber sonst wüsste ich jetzt nicht, was sonst noch war.
Okay, ich verstehe. Wie sagt das Überbrüchen aus?
Das war das, was ich vorher gegessen hatte.
Nur Speisebrei, oder?
Ja, genau.
Okay, okay. Sie haben nur einmal übergeben, oder?
Ja, ich musste mich nur einmal übergeben.
Okay, ich verstehe. Herr Schäffer, ich hatte jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrem allgemeinen Gesundheitszustand. Wie ist denn Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist er gut, aber nachdem ich mich jetzt übergeben habe, ist er jetzt nicht so gut. Und wie gesagt, ja, die Schmerzen, die machen mir schon ein bisschen zu schaffen, ja.
Okay, okay. Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Abautosug genommen?
Also das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, aber eigentlich würde ich sagen, das ist immer gleich mein Gewicht.
Okay, sehr gut. Ich denke, normalerweise schlafen Sie gut, aber?
Ja, also jetzt, also eigentlich kann ich nicht immer gut schlafen. Ich muss halt immer sehr früh aufstehen.
Ich bin Bäcker von Beruf und muss immer sehr früh morgens in die Backstube.
Und dadurch habe ich natürlich einen anderen Tagesrhythmus als andere Leute.
Aber wenn der eigentlich eingehalten wird, dann kann ich eigentlich gut schlafen. Muss ich auch.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, beim Wasserlassen haben Sie Probleme.
Ja, ja, das ist sehr unangenehm.
Wie geht es bei Stuhlgang?
Der Stuhlgang ist eigentlich normal, würde ich sagen.
Okay. Beim Wasserlassen, Sie haben Schmerzen.
Ja, heftige Schmerzen, ja.
Ja, Sie müssen zu viel Toilette geben.
Ich muss, ja, immer und dann kommt fast gar nichts und es brennt dann ziemlich, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe. Okay.
Und was mir aufgefallen ist, also das sah so ein bisschen aus, als ob da Blut mit in dem Urin drin wäre.
Blut, okay. Okay. Fühlen Sie sich feberig?
Habe ich jetzt nicht so richtig drüber nachgedacht. Vielleicht so ein bisschen, dass mir ein bisschen warm könnte gut sein.
Ja, also so richtig gut fühle ich mich halt nicht, aber ich dachte, das hängt mit den Schmerzen zusammen.
Könnte sein, dass ich ein bisschen Temperatur habe, ja.
Aber Sie haben nicht gemessen.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, nee.
Okay, okay. Haben Sie Ihre Monatsblutung regelmäßig oder?
Ich bin ein Mann, liebe.
Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung. Meine Fehler.
Jetzt würde Sie gerne nach Ihren beschädigten Vorerkrankungen fragen.
Herr Schäfer, haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, also vor ein paar Jahren hat man mal festgestellt, dass ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe und da nehme ich jetzt auch Tabletten dagegen.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Ja, das ist so ungefähr vier Jahre her.
Okay. Was nehmen Sie für?
Da nehme ich Diltiazim. Da nehme ich morgens und abends eine Tablette.
Okay. Wissen Sie die Dosierung?
Ich meine, da steht Diltiazim 90 drauf.
90, okay.
Ja, und dann habe ich ja durch die Arbeit bedingt so ein bisschen, habe ich ziemlich häufig im rechten Unterarm so eine Sehenscheidenentzündung.
Und ja, da muss ich manchmal dann so eine Orthese tragen und wenn die Schmerzen ein bisschen stärker sind, dann nehme ich da auch mal so eine Diclofenaxsalbe.
Aber die brauche ich nicht ständig.
In welchen Händen?
Im rechten Arm.
Rechte Unterarm, ja.
Haben Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich wurde noch nie operiert, nein.
Also auch nicht als Kind, nee, ich wüsste, nee. Ich glaube, ich bin tatsächlich noch nie operiert worden, nee.
Sehr gut. Haben Sie eventuell Allergien oder Unfalltäglichkeiten?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich eine blöde Allergie für meinen Beruf. Und zwar bin ich auf Wespenstiche allergisch, auf Wespengift.
Und ja, da muss ich tatsächlich auch, also in der Saison muss ich immer so einen Pin da mit mir rumtragen, damit ich da im Zweifelsfall mir eine Spritze geben kann.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Und rauchen Sie, Herr Schoffer?
Oh, ich bin sehr stolz, ich rauche seit fünf Jahren nicht mehr.
Sehr gut, sehr gut so. Ich gratuliere.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie gerauft?
Seit ich 20 war ungefähr, da habe ich damit angefangen. Und ja, das sind so 22 Jahre.
Wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie?
Ah, so ein Päckchen am Tag war das schon.
Okay, rauchen Sie? Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Also richtig Alkohol, ich trinke abends ein paar Gläser Bier, ja, wenn ich aus der Backstube komme, wenn es warm war und zum Runterkommen so zwei, drei Gläser Bier trinke ich am Abend, ja.
Am Abend zwei, drei Bier, oder?
Ja, abends zwei, drei Bier zum Abendessen und dann noch eins so, ja, vor dem Schlafen gehen.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet, ich denke?
Ich lebe getrennt im Augenblick von meiner Frau. Ja, wir sind im Treibungsjahr.
Haben Sie auch Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder, die sind aber bei meiner Frau.
Okay, ich hoffe Sie sind gesund.
Die Kinder? Ja, das hoffe ich auch, ja doch, also denen geht es gut, ja.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt Sie ist Bäcker?
Ich bin Bäcker, ich habe eine eigene Bäckerei.
Okay, und nun hatte er noch ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie. Wie geht es Ihren Eltern?
Ja, das sind halt alte Leute, ja. Meine Mutter hat so ein bisschen Probleme mit der Wirbelsäule, dass die so eine Verkrümmung hat.
Aber ansonsten hat die eigentlich nichts.
Ja, aber mein Vater, der hat so eine Durchblutungsstörung in den Beinen.
Und dem wurde jetzt vor gar nicht so langer Zeit, musste dem eine große Zähne amputiert werden, weil das irgendwie nicht richtig durchblutet war, ja.
Okay, haben Sie auch Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe zwei Brüder, aber da wüsste ich jetzt nicht, ob die irgendwie krank sind.
Eigentlich sind die, glaube ich, fit.
Okay, vielen Dank für das Gespräch.
Als nächsten Schritt werde ich Sie körperliche Untersuchung und so wie Blut abnehmen und eine Tereuntersuchung veranlassen.
Ich möchte Sie nun bitten, einen Moment draußen Platz zu nehmen.
Mittlerweile bespreche ich Ihren Fall mit meinem Chefarzt. Im Anschluss komme ich wieder zu Ihnen und erkenke alles.
Das ist gut, okay.
Hat jemand noch Bergen? Haben Sie Stillfrost?
Stillfrost? Nö, hat er nicht.
Haben Sie Taubhausgefühl oder Kribbeln in den Beinen?
Nee, überhaupt nicht, nein.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder festhält?
Ich habe jetzt erst seit zwei Stunden so heftig. Ich habe nicht festgestellt, dass da irgendwas hilft, was die besser macht.
Um Verdauungsbeschwerden hat er verneint.
Haben die Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich begonnen?
Also die Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen haben langsam angefangen.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass es immer schlimmer wurde, aber jetzt diese Rückenschmerzen, das ist ganz plötzlich gekommen. Mit einem Mal fing das an.
Danke. Bitte schön.
Okay, guten Tag, Frau Chefärztin. Ich möchte Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen. Haben Sie Zeit?
Ja, sicher, natürlich.
Es handelt sich um einen 48-jährigen Patienten namens Johannes Schäfer,
der sich heute wegen kampfartig brennenden, dückend, rechtzeitigen Rückenschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung im Ingenieurebereich bei uns vorgestellt hat.
Wir beschwerden, wir stehen seit zwei Stunden und haben langsam begonnen.
Der Schmerzinterstät wurde auf der Skala mit 7 von 10 bewertet. Die Beschwerden würden sich im Laufe der Zeit verstärken.
Begleitend berichtete er über Neu-Vomitus in Appetanz.
Ja, das war es. Die Vomitus war nur speisebrei und gegen diese Beschwerden nehme er keine Medikamente.
Also er hat noch nichts dagegen eingenommen.
Bis auf die Zürich und Polykyl ergaben sich keine Auffälligkeiten.
Das sind ja entscheidende Auffälligkeiten in dem Zusammenhang.
Ja.
Wo ist er?
Bitte schön.
Okay. Die Fragen nach weiteren Beschwerden wurden verneint.
An Vorerkrankungen sind arteriöle Hypotonie und im rechten und unteren Arm habe sie Schmerzen.
Er hat keine Operationen. An Medikamenten nehmen sie die Serien 90 mg morgens und abends.
Er hat eine Wespenallergie, die sich als Anaphylaxie auslöst.
Noch in einem Medikament ergab sich, dass der Patient nicht mehr raucht.
Vor 22 Jahren hat er eine Packung pro Tag geraucht. Das entspricht 22 Packungsjahren.
Er trinkt abends zwei oder drei Bier.
In der Familienanamnese hat die Mutter Skolios und der Vater Weinblut.
Ich glaube, weil er große Blut hat. Aber ich bin nicht sicher.
In der sozialen Anamnese gab es einen Patienten. Er ist Bäcker. Er ist getrennt mit seiner Frau.
Von seiner Frau? Wie?
Er hat drei Kinder. Sie sind gesund. Er hat zwei Brüder und sie sind auch gesund.
Als Verdachtdiagnose hatte ich eine Pyrenephritis.
Könnte es differenzial diagnostisch sein?
Es könnte eine Carcinoma sein.
Was spricht denn für die Pyrenephritis?
Es kann auch eine Uglithiasis sein.
Oder ein regulärer Hahnwegsinfekt. Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Zu weiteren Abklärungen würde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Im Grunde genommen muss ich ein Erzugungszeichen gucken.
Was machen Sie als erstes? Mit Ihren Händen? Mit Ihren Augen?
Ich habe nicht in Deutsch diese Wörter.
Klopchal vielleicht?
Wo denn? Wo klopfen Sie?
Klopch-Matsch-Hoff.
Wo ist das klopfschmerzhaft am Kopf?
Im Nierenlager.
Was gucken Sie noch?
Im Blut.
Oder was tasten Sie noch?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung gucke ich noch.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich es gar nicht gucken kann.
Sie tasten natürlich den Bauch auch ab?
Ja. Und?
Der Pfanz ist über uns. Wir gucken.
Noch was?
Ich glaube, wir müssen Bauchpapier machen.
Auf alle Fälle, ja. Sicherlich Bauch.
Aber worauf achten Sie denn dabei?
Der Mann erzählt, dass er ständig zur Toilette muss, weil er Wasser lassen muss.
Was gucken Sie denn?
Wir müssen vorerst die Gitarre...
Möglicherweise, ja. Aber Sie müssen erst mal gucken, ob die Blase voll ist.
Gut. Dann wäre es vielleicht auch noch sinnvoll, die Lymphknotenstation abzutasten, wenn der eine Entzündung hat.
Gut. Jetzt schauen wir weiter. Was machen Sie noch?
Blut abnehmen.
Und was wird untersucht im Blut?
Ich muss entzündliche Parameter wie BSG, CAP, Leukocytos und noch Blühstatus.
Wir müssen gucken, im Blühstatus, Nitrit erhöht, Leukocyt erhöht.
Leukocyt, Erotocyt, ja. Was noch?
Und ich habe Nitrit gesagt.
Okay.
Und wir müssen auch Urinkultur mit Regen- und Resistenztestung.
Also Urinkultur, okay.
Auch wir müssen Atomansonographie veranlassen.
Falls brauchen wir... wir können...
Was kann man in der Sonographie sehen?
Wir können große Überteller sehen.
Genau, ja.
Und noch...
Wofür würde das sprechen?
Entschuldigung?
Was erkennen wir, wenn der Uriter vergrößert ist, erweitert ist?
Worauf lässt er schließen?
Weiß nicht.
Warum ist er denn vergrößert?
Warum? Weil es gibt eine Entzündung und das...
Es gibt ein Abschlusshindernis vermutlich.
Ja, es gibt ein Abschlusshindernis und deswegen staut sich da der Urin.
Ja.
So.
Gut, ja, das könnte man sehen.
Was könnte man unter Umständen auch noch sehen im Ultraschall?
Im Ultraschall...
Man kann auch sehen...
Kann man Steinserien... ja.
Wenn der groß genug ist, kann man den sehen, ne?
Genau, gut.
Ja.
Im Folgenden könnte man natürlich auch noch aufwendigere Untersuchungen machen.
Aber das würde ja erstmal so für die erste Diagnose wahrscheinlich schon einiges an Informationen geben.
Wenn sich das bestätigt, dass dieser Patient einen Stein hat, einen Anleiterstern, was wäre dann die Therapie?
Wenn der Patient hat Stein, wir müssen zuerst aufs Reichen der Flüssigkeit zuvörern.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Analystikum.
Ja, der hat ja stärkste Schmerzen, ne?
Ja, stärke Schmerzen und Spasmonitikum werden wir auch geben.
Genau.
Falls wir brauchen, können wir auch Antibiotikum geben.
Wenn wir eine Entzündung feststellen, ja, okay.
Okay, genau. Gut. Und was für Therapieoptionen gibt es dann weiterhin?
Ja, hier müssen wir...
Und wovon hängen die ab?
Wir müssen auch in diesem Fall Antibiotika bereiten.
Das sagten Sie gerade, aber was für Optionen gibt es noch, um dem Patienten nachhaltig zu helfen?
Und wovon hängt das ab, wie diese Optionen aussehen?
ECWL, aber ich... ESWL.
Ah, Stoßwellentherapie meinen Sie, ne?
Ja.
Ja, okay. Aber wovon hängt denn das ab, was wir machen müssen?
Ja, das bedeutet, das hängt von der Vergrößerung.
Und der Größe des Steins hängt es ab.
Ja.
Ein großer Stein wird anders behandelt als ein kleiner Stein.
Ja, wenn es ein kleiner Stein ist, was macht man dann?
Man kann... man kann nur... wenn der Stein ist zu klein, man kann eine Konservativtherapie geben.
Genau.
Und viel Flüssigkeit...
Genau, spülen, spülen, spülen, ja, genau.
Und dann hoffen, dass er so abgeht, ja, genau.
Und unter Schmerzmitteln natürlich, klar.
Und wenn er größer ist, dann hatten Sie schon gesagt, Stoßwellentherapie, ne?
Gott, oh Gott, wie heißen die?
Extra-korporale Stoßwellen-Lithotripti...
Oh Gott, das ist so schwierig, ja.
Oder, ja, wenn es also gar nicht geht, muss man das Ding möglicherweise auch laparoskopisch entfernen.
Ja.
Gut.
Ja, lassen Sie uns...
Ja, also halten Sie mich über Ihren Patienten auf dem Laufenden, ne?
Wir gucken nachher nach dem...
Und ich bin gespannt, was rauskommt.
So.
Wir können gleich zur Manöverkritik übergehen.
Ja, heute waren irgendwie einige Hindernisse auf dem Weg.
Ach, das ist die ESWL, extra-korporale Stoßwellentherapie, ja.
Heute waren einige Hindernisse auf dem Weg sprachlich und ja, dann nachher im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch auch inhaltlich.
Das war nicht Ihr Fall, ne?
Mit dem konnten Sie nicht viel anfangen.
Eigentlich hat der ja schöne, eindeutige Symptome gehabt, ne?
Der hatte schon ein bisschen Probleme mit dem Wasser lassen.
Und dann ist es mit einem mal richtig krass geworden mit den Schmerzen.
Und ja, also ich denke, Anamnese war auch ganz okay.
Dann, lass mal eben gucken.
Ja, was mir dann eigentlich nicht so gut gefallen hat, war im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch waren ein paar Sachen, die eigentlich einfach so nicht gesagt waren.
Zum Beispiel haben Sie gesagt, die Schmerzen hätten langsam begonnen.
Nee, diese heftigen Schmerzen, wegen derer er ja kommt, der wäre ja nicht wegen der brennenden Schmerzen beim Wasser lassen, wäre der nicht gekommen.
Da wäre er morgen zu seinem Hausarzt gegangen.
Der ist ja gekommen, weil er mit einmal diese Hammer-Schmerzen da in der Flanke hatte.
So, einmal diese Lokalisation Flanke.
Das wäre irgendwie so ein, denke ich, ein schöner Fachbegriff, den man da unterbringen könnte.
Also wo waren die Schmerzen? Lokalisiert, rechte Seite, rechte Flanke.
Und sie haben eben plötzlich angefangen. Mit einmal Hammer-Schmerzen.
Vor zwei Stunden konnte der sagen, oh Mann, jetzt geht es aber los. Jetzt habe ich starke Schmerzen.
Die haben nicht langsam angefangen, sondern plötzlich.
Dann haben Sie zwar gesagt, Sie haben das so gesagt, außer Dysurie und Polakisurie hat er sonst keine Probleme.
Das sind aber Probleme und die hängen natürlich unmittelbar mit dieser Erkrankung zusammen.
Und was Sie eben nicht gesagt haben, der hätte ja auch eine Hämaturie. Der hätte ja gesagt, er hat Blut gesehen im Urin.
Und das ist natürlich so etwas, was dann auch ziemlich eindeutig für den Stein spricht.
Dass da irgendwo was gestört ist.
So, dann haben Sie gesagt, dass er sich einmal übergeben hat. Fieberunklar. Das war schön.
Dann Vorerkrankung, alles gut. Ja, der hat gesagt, er hat eine Sehenscheidenentzündung im rechten Arm durch körperliche Belastung.
Das sind nicht nur Schmerzen. Das ist ja eine diagnostizierte Erkrankung.
Das ist ja so ein Trick der Prüfer, dass diese Nebenerkrankungen manchmal so als Nebenspurbrau verwenden,
um dann da auch nochmal nachzufragen, ob jemand auf einem anderen Gebiet auch noch fit ist.
Und da sprachlich zurechtkommt. Also auch da sollten Sie die Fachbegriffe haben.
Er hat eine Sehenscheidenentzündung. So, dann kommen wir zur Familienanamnese.
Da haben Sie so einen kleinen Exkurs gemacht. Da hatte ich Ihnen ja geraten.
Sagen Sie nicht einfach nur Familienanamnese. Sowieso.
Da haben Sie in der Familienanamnese, ja, da sollte man aber schon sagen, gab der Patient an, dass, so, Skoliose der Mutter,
haben Sie richtig erkannt. Richtig, klar. Beim Vater hat er aber gesagt, der hat Durchblutungsstörungen.
Das ist keine Varikosis. Das ist eine PHVK.
Denn wegen der Varikosis wird nicht der C amputiert.
Sondern da muss es schon eine ordentliche Durchblutungsstörung sein.
Eigentlich ja schon ein PHVK-Stadium 4.
Auch da müssen Sie damit rechnen, dass Ihre Prüfer nochmal nachfragen.
Gut, dann haben Sie sich ein bisschen schwergetan. Natürlich mit der Diagnose.
Was spricht für die Nierenbeckenentzündungen, für die Pyrloinitritis?
Die Schmerzen, ja, okay. Aber dieses plötzliche Auftreten von so heftigen Schmerzen,
dann hätten die langsamer angefangen, würde ich denken.
Und das Plötzliche spricht schon eher für das Steingeschehen.
Und ja, das waren die Sachen.
Ja, und dann wussten Sie aber nicht so richtig, was Sie mit dem Patienten diagnostisch anfangen sollen.
Also diese typische Geschichte Nierenlagerklopfschmerz, das sollte eigentlich kommen, denke ich auch.
Und eine gefüllte Harnblase, ob die Blase hoch steht, das sollte man eigentlich auch, denke ich mal,
oder Bauch abtasten oder so, auf die Idee müsste man schon kommen.
Dann klar, Labor, sowohl Blut als auch U-Status ist klar.
Da könnte man vielleicht noch gucken, ob es im Urin Anzeichen gibt für übermäßige Kalk- oder Oxalsäurefunde.
Gut, dann haben Sie Sonographie gesagt, Erweiterung, Harnleiter.
Und natürlich kann man auch das Nierenbecken dann ein bisschen vielleicht beurteilen im Ultraschall,
aber vor allen Dingen kann man eben den Stein sehen.
Gut, aber dann kamen natürlich die richtigen Sachen für die Therapie.
Wärme, Flüssigkeit, krampflösende Mittel und schmerzlösende Mittel natürlich.
Und dann die Therapie abhängig von der Größe des Steines, das ist auf alle Fälle eine wichtige Geschichte.
Und auch wo der sich befindet, das kam als Hinweis doch von einem Kollegen oder einer Kollegin.
Nicht nur die Größe, auch die Lage, wo der gerade sitzt, entscheidet, was man machen kann.
Gut, da haben Sie sich aber dann auch sprachlich wirklich verheddert.
Also, als Sie inhaltlich nicht mehr sicher waren, sind Ihre Sätze nicht mehr korrekt gewesen.
Und das ist so ein bisschen ein Manko, dass Sie dann sprachliche Unsicherheiten haben.
Wenn Sie auf sicherem Terrain sind, ja, also bei den Fragen gegenüber dem Patienten,
gibt es sprachlich keine großen Unsicherheiten.
Aber wenn Sie selber was erklären müssen, haben Sie wirklich Formulierungs-Schwierigkeiten.
Das ist mir beim letzten Mal schon ein bisschen aufgefallen, habe ich Ihnen das schon gesagt.
Und das ist jetzt heute ziemlich signifikant gewesen.
Und ich meine, das mag jetzt noch mit dem Computer-Problem,
also dass das Handy mit einmal nicht mehr funktioniert, noch zusammenhängt.
Da ist mir auch aufgefallen, dass Sie also immer auf Ihren Zettel geguckt haben.
Sie haben gar nicht mehr in die Kamera geguckt.
Und das sollten Sie natürlich im Gespräch mit Ihrem Oberarzt oder mit dem simulierten Prüfer,
da sollten Sie das vermeiden, dass Sie nur auf Ihre Zettel gucken.
Sondern bleiben Sie da in Blickkontakt mit dem.
Und natürlich dürfen Sie zwischendurch auf Ihr Konzept gucken und auf Ihren Zettel,
was Sie sich aufgeschrieben haben, aber nicht da drin versinken.
Das kann ich Ihnen nur empfehlen.
Ja, versuchen Sie, sich fit zu machen, dass Sie Formulierungen haben,
wenn Sie was gefragt werden.
Wirklich.
Anders kann ich es jetzt nicht sagen.
Das darf Sie nicht völlig aus der Bahn werfen.
Sonst erwischen Sie Sie auf einen kalten Fuß.
Also das ist schlecht.
Versuchen Sie, ruhig zu bleiben und richtige Sätze zu machen,
obwohl Sie unter Druck sind.
Das ist einfach so.
Versuchen Sie vielleicht nochmal, sich eine schriftliche Zusammenfassung von dem Ding zu machen,
dass Sie selber nochmal die Fallbeschreibung machen.
Ich kann Ihnen anbieten, was ich kürzlich auch gemacht habe,
dass Sie mir das schicken und ich Ihnen eine Korrektur zukommen lasse,
dass Sie einfach nochmal wirklich einen ausformulierten Bericht machen,
wie Sie es sagen würden.
Und dann kann man es nochmal unter Umständen korrigieren.
Das kann ich Ihnen nur anbieten.
Gut, ja, wie gesagt, schnelle Anamnese, aber viele Nachfragen.
Das, was ich der Allgemeinheit schon so gesagt habe,
Sie haben ein paar Dinge nicht gefragt, die würde ich aber auch für nicht sinnvoll halten in diesem Fall.
Weil der Impfstatus ist irgendwie irrelevant, wenn der mit Pippi-Schwierigkeiten kommt.
Und genauso die Reiseanamnese.
Es ist nicht sehr wahrscheinlich, dass seine Reise jetzt irgendwo den großen Unterschied gemacht hat.
Und insofern finde ich es eigentlich legitim, diese Fragen nicht zu stellen.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie Ihre Prüfer darüber denken, ob die sagen,
ja, da hätte man aber auch noch nachfragen müssen.
Ich finde immer, dass es eigentlich vernünftig ist, praktisch symptomorientiert weiter zu fragen.
Denn als Patient bin ich ja eigentlich ein bisschen genervt,
wenn ich komme mit Bauchschmerzen oder Flankenschmerzen und Pippi-Problemen.
Wenn mich dann jemand fragt, haben Sie Kopfschmerzen oder haben Sie Herzklopfen?
Völlig idiotisch.
Dann werde ich schon auch ein bisschen grantig und sage, ich habe mir doch gesagt, was ich habe.
Ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Aber ich denke, die Vollständigkeit ist nicht immer das ganz große Thema.
Aber das kann natürlich sein, dass Ihre Prüfer da anderer Meinung sind.
Ich kann das Ihnen nicht voraussagen.
Gut, ich hoffe, ich habe Sie jetzt nicht allzu sehr entmutigt.
Ich kann Ihnen nur das Angebot machen, schicken Sie einen fertigen Arztbrief mir zu.
Ich weiß nicht, haben Sie mitgeschrieben neulich, als ich meine E-Mail geschickt habe?